Galbraith: So welcome
to Bespin on the Open Web.
I'm Ben Galbraith.
Almaer: And I am Dion Almaer.
We most recently created
this thing Bespin
that we'll talk about
on the web technologies,
but we also founded ajaxian.com
where we gather the community
to chat about all things Ajax.
Galbraith: And today we work
at a company called Mozilla.
You're familiar with Mozilla,
of course.
We work in the labs division
of Mozilla.
And at Mozilla Labs,
we're working on a bunch
of interesting things
that we hope will drive
the Web forward.
Almaer: So we've got these
different kind of visualizations
that people have done
of what the browser can do
in the future in all of these
kind of crazy, futuristic ways
of accessing your history
and kind of seeing
where the different data is
and playing around
with different, cool things
that have been done.
Like, Adaptive Path did a pretty
fun Aurora visualization,
so there's all this kind of fun,
future-y lab stuff
where people pontificate
on where we'll browse
in the future.
Galbraith: That's part
of what we do at Labs.
But, you know, really, when you
move away from science fiction
and you look at what
the browsers are actually doing,
you see the interesting trend
that browsers aren't turning
into "Minority Report."
They're actually getting simpler
over time.
But what's fascinating,
at the same time,
is that the engine underlying
these browsers
is getting more
and more interesting,
and so that's what Dion and I do
at Mozilla Labs
is focus on how
we can harness
this increasingly powerful
Rev runtime engine
to do cool things
for developers.
Almaer: And when the Ajax
revolution kind of kicked off,
these were the types
of sessions
that people were talking about
at events like this.
It was the very low-level API--
in this case, access in XHR--
to be able to talk back
to the server.
But those days are kind
of long behind us.
We've already abstracted on top.
We've got these great libraries.
More than just GWT,
which is fantastic.
There's a whole ecosystem
of libraries that are out there,
one for every star
that's on this point.
Every week, someone comes up
with their own Ajax library.
And we kind of think
that we've nailed
kind of these DSLs for doing
this little AJAXy stuff,
and it's time to move on.
Galbraith: Yeah, Vic talked
about in the keynote
to start out Google I/O
the sort of future horizon
of technologies, and we're
super-excited about that.
It's clear that we're
at the cutting edge,
the cusp of seeing
what's possible on the Web
be revolutionized.
And so what we want to do
with Bespin is explore how
we can apply these technologies
to developer tools,
and in today's talk,
we want to also talk about
these technologies with you,
some of the newer Open Web
technologies that we used,
and why we're so excited
about them
and why we think
they're so disruptive.
Almaer: So, exactly right.
We were playing around with
a lot of these technologies,
doing a lot of demos,
and we kind of wanted
to take these things
and these cool things
that people have been talking
about and seeing how far
you can actually go.
You know, so the great example
with Wave--
in our world,
we're in developer tools.
We have this, like,
really nice advantage,
which is, you guys, developers,
I don't know how many of you
are running IE for example,
so we can go
with these modern browsers,
I believe they put it,
to kind of push and see
what's going on
because in the drudgery
that we sometimes have
where we have to kind of work
with these--
you know, my mum and dad
that are running IE6.
We don't get to play
with the new engine,
so we have the luxury
to kind of play around.
In developer tools,
would something
that people wouldn't think of
as maybe being
kind of running on the Web,
and that was to build a,
you know, top class code editor
and experience.
Galbraith: Something that was
not only rivaling Desktop class,
that actually was better
than what you could do
on the desktop.
And so we thought, you know,
if we could build
an editor that you could
just use from anywhere--
from a mobile phone
to a Web browser...
You don't have to bring
your code environment with you,
it's just always there,
that would be cool.
If it was really simple to use.
So a lot of the editors
that we've seen out there
require familiarity
with the tool,
a large learning curve,
and they're really intimidating.
And we wanted something
you could just jump right into.
And we wanted it to be
incredibly fast and responsive.
We wanted to make sure
that you never felt
like, "Geez, you know,
it's not keeping up with me.
There's a performance problem."
If this is gonna be successful,
it's got to be lightning fast.
Almaer: And then collaboration
is a key piece to this.
And again we're really excited
to see Wave.
I've worked at Google
in the past,
so I've had the luxury of
knowing a little bit about it.
And we want
this rock-solid collaboration.
As programmers,
we're kind of used to,
other than some
of the thought workers over here
that pair with each other
every time they write some code,
they're kind of sitting in the
cave, kind of writing this code.
And we want to explore
what it would be like
with a more social
environment,
so we want this rock-solid
collaboration built in
to your code editing
experience.
I'm also a command line
junkie,
whether it's Quicksilver
to do fun things on the Mac
or just the UNIX command line.
We wanted to kind of put that
into the code editing
experience too
and make it very, very social.
So there's another lab project
called Ubiquity.
Ubiquity's all about kind
of having this command line
for the Web
with these social commands,
so I can go out and write
and interesting command
that now ties
into the Wave APIs,
and Ben can say, "I want
to subscribe to Dion's command."
And as I do new version,
he gets it in his command line.
So we want to explore
how we can build
a really discoverable command
line that people can kind of
evolve on and share
together.
And then finally,
this is really important.
I used to be an old eMacs guy
and was one of those somewhat
sad people at university
that, like, read me email
through eMacs,
and that was kind of
everything.
And I love the fact
that it was totally self-hosted,
and with all these Web
developers that are here,
like, how can you go
and extend your editor,
your IDE?
It can be pretty hard.
Some of 'em have different kind
of plug-in APIs
that you can play with,
but we wanted it
to be fully self-hosted
in just the Web technology.
Just JavaScript, CSS,
HTML.
And so we want to make it
so anyone can extend it
'cause you're in this tool,
you know,
eight-plus hours a day
sometimes.
Let's make sure
that it can be the tool
that you really want.
So that's really
what we wanted to do.
Galbraith: So let's give you
a quick demo of what we have.
It's a work in progress.
Let's turn on Mirroring.
So let's go into a file.
So this is the Bespin editor.
And one of the interesting
things that we did is,
in order
to get performance,
we actually wound up
coding the code editor
from scratch using Canvas,
one of these HTML5 technologies
we've been talking about.
And so...
can't start the function.
Foo: function.
So one of the things
that I hope I'm showing
is that it actually is able
to keep up with us
really well as we type,
which was really important
to us
because we hadn't really seen
HTML code editors
perform that well,
and we have seen a few
that perform well
on files of reasonable size.
This is, you know, 1,500 lines
of code,
so what happens if we sort
of step it up a notch
and go to 50,000 lines
of code.
Almaer: We consider this a best
practice for your project.
Galbraith: It's all one code...
Almaer: One large file.
And so we want to optimize
for that use case.
Galbraith:
Yeah, we just find it--
because directory addressing's
so slow,
we have a lot of files
in the directory,
it's all one file
on the Bespin team.
But even with a really large,
obscene file,
we're able to have performance
still keep up with us
with live syntax highlighted
and all that stuff.
So we were really happy
that we were able
to achieve performance,
and because we did all
the rendering ourselves,
we decided to just kind
of be obnoxious and do things
like, you know,
translucent scrollbars
and things that you can't
really do on the Web platform
unless you do it all
on your own.
So, that's--
oh, and we also
have full undo/redo and stuff
like that too.
So that's the basic core
editor.
Almaer: And then I should show
quickly the command line?
Galbraith:
Yeah, please.
Almaer:
So the command line showed--
this is a little bit
of an experiment.
We have this pie menu thing.
Which, again, 'cause we're doing
all of this in Canvas,
we can animate
and do fun things.
Again, I kind of mentioned,
like, Quicksilver-like,
and you can go through and run
these whole slew of commands
that you have access to, and
you can look at your history,
and double-click to run again,
and single-click to put it in,
and all
these kind of fun things.
And what we should actually
show you
is just kind of what it's like
to actually write
a simple command, say.
So there's a Bespin settings
project that everyone gets
when you get an account.
And I open up
the calculate command.
It's just a JSONObject
that mimics the Ubiquity API.
We just give it a name
and the arguments it takes
and things like this.
And you just get
an execute function,
and there's some other things,
like doing validation
and the like.
But that's just where you kind
of write your code,
and then you can go through
and run it.
Now at first,
I don't have this command,
but what I can do
is I can go into my settings,
and I can turn it on.
So I'll go here into
my config,
and I've had commented out
loading that particular command.
So uncomment that guy.
I can run config
to force the load.
And now I can calculate
something on the fly.
And then people can subscribe
to these commands and like.
So we found the people just
going off and kind of writing
their own little commands
as a very easy way
for developers to just extend
what they're doing,
especially since you don't have
to think too much
about the UI and the like.
But we also have APIs where,
from the commands,
you can then come up
and access the APIs
and do different things
like that.
Galbraith: Cool.
Almaer: Shall we go back to it?
We'll show more
about Bespin in a bit.
Galbraith: Yeah, let's get
back to the slides
and talk a little bit more
about this
because that's really
what you want to see,
is more slides.
Um...
let me turn off Mirroring
just because we need to see
a little bit in advance
what's happening.
Almaer: So we're gonna talk
about the different technologies
that we've used in Bespin
and then kind of look
at some of the gotchas
and what we've kind of
experienced as we used them
and things we had to do
to kind of make this work
a little bit too.
Galbraith: Well,
you saw the full slide,
so I'll just put it up there.
So we talked
about Canvas.
And we'd actually like
to talk a little bit more
about Canvas
and how we've used it.
And then we'll also be
talking about
some of the other
technologies
that played an important role
here in what we've done.
So Canvas--I just want to blow
through these really quick
and just point out that
traditionally we've been limited
to three primitives
on the Web--
text, rectangles,
and images.
And Canvas blows that out
so we can do arbitrary rendering
of all kinds.
And you can actually do
some things
that are not
immediately obvious.
Once you mash a video
in here too,
like, take video pull frames
out of the video
and use Canvas to composite
the frames on the fly
and do things like, you know,
detect the light sources
and put elements inside,
they're all using JavaScript,
Canvas, video, all that stuff.
So Canvas let's us do things
that are pretty amazing
that have never been possible,
but you might be thinking,
"Well, we have Flash
and Silverlight
and other plug-ins that do it."
We just want to review
the specific reasons
why we think Canvas
is so revolutionary,
even though with plug-ins,
we've been able to do
some arbitrary rendering
before.
One of which is there's
absolutely no start-up delay,
which is huge,
especially with some
of the plug-ins out there
that block the browser
while they start up.
And they're available
on mobile devices today.
There's no need to wait
until mobile versions
of these plug-ins
are properly optimized.
You can go use them
on certain classes
of mobile devices
that are very popular,
like the iPhone,
that have full-featured browsers
out there.
Rendering fidelity
with the browser--
some plug-ins actually render
their own fonts.
And if you're into the
micro-details like we are,
we thinks those things
really, really matter
when you have text
that just looks different
from the rest of
the web page,
from the rest
of what the user expects,
and having Canvas actually there
using the same pipeline
as the rest of the browser
makes a big difference.
Almaer: And then
the whole bridge system.
So right now there's really
no interesting ways
to bridge over to Flash
and Silverlight and the like,
but you have to go through
this marshaling experience,
which can be
a little bit slow,
even though things are being
worked on there,
and you have to do
that little bit of Swiff stuff
or whatever it is
on the other side
to bridge through
to the system.
Here we just kind of
bypass that, and,
as we'll see when we look
at some of the Canvas stuff,
it's just JavaScript
with a little API,
and that's all you need
to worry about.
And then kind of wrapping it
all together,
it's not this separate plug-in
with a separate lifecycle.
It's native
into the environment,
into the browser platform
itself.
Galbraith: So the interesting
thing about Canvas
is that it actually came
to us as a proprietary extension
that Apple did,
but the thing that we thought
was interesting is just how
far ahead of the game Apple was
because Apple took the Web
and basically made it
the desktop program remodel
for their widgeting system,
and it seems like,
three or four years later,
we're finally catching up
with his idea
that the Web can actually be
the desktop platform.
And we'll talk more about that.
And then the other modern
browsers that are out there
actually have this technology
too, as we've discussed.
And there's the question
of IE.
What do you do
with IE?
Well, it turns out there are
ways to get Canvas in IE.
Google has created
a VML bridge.
VML's a proprietary vector
graphics language
that's been in IE forever.
And there's a JavaScript bridge
that lets you use Canvas
on top of VML really slowly.
And then there's a number
of other bridges out there
that are based on Flash
and Silverlight.
These are all works
in progress.
None of them are really great
in quality right now,
but if you look at Yahoo! Pipes
for example,
Yahoo! Pipes has built
a really great application
on top of the earlier VML Canvas
bridge that I mentioned.
And then we have
an experimental extension
at Mozilla that takes
our own Canvas implementation
in Firefox and packages that up
as an ActiveX plug-in
and lets you use it
in Internet Explorer.
So there are a number of ways
to get Canvas to IE.
For us, we just said,
"Hey, we're not
actually gonna support IE."
And that worked out
pretty well.
[laughter]
[stammering]
Not that we don't like IE.
Almaer:
Yes, exactly.
Especially since Chris Wilson
is here.
We love IE.
We're passionate about it.
Galbraith: Hey, Chris.
Almaer: SVG.
A few people,
after we launched this,
sort of really like SVG,
said, "Why did you use Canvas
and not SVG?
It's got different advantages."
You know, we definitely think
SVG is doing some great stuff,
we've seen some great
applications with it,
but, "A," it wasn't really
our background.
Ben's a Java 2-D kind of guru,
so if it were--
his knowledge was already--
and also frankly the Canvas API,
as you'll see,
is very, very small,
lightweight API
the browser's gonna implement
easily, whereas SVG is,
you know, x-thousand pages,
and then there's the SVG live,
and you get into kind of some
of the same issues
we see with HTML
where we get the different
browsers supporting it.
But a lot of great things
are happening.
There's some really great
Googlers who are doing
some really good stuff
with SVG.
So we're excited to see what
kind of comes out of that too.
Galbraith: So we've all seen
a lot of slides by now
about Canvas,
what you can do with it,
and we thought,
if you were interested,
we could actually start coding
with Canvas
to give you more of a feel
of how it actually works.
And we thought, you know,
it's one thing
to create a code editor
from scratch in Canvas,
it's another to create
a code editor
from scratch using
your code editor from scratch
in a live demo
using Canvas.
And if you guys would like
to see that,
we could spend a couple
of minutes just writing
the code editor from scratch
in Canvas
in front of you, just to see
what that's like.
We obviously can't get
a whole lot of features in there
because there's a lot more
we want to talk about.
Would that be interesting?
Should we do that?
Okay, we'll do that
for a few minutes.
Um, let's see how far we get.
I reserve the right
to bail.
Almaer: We got
to get syntax highlighting...
Galbraith: Yeah,
that's not gonna happen.
So let's just go
right into Bespin
and see how far we get.
So let's pull up
the command line here.
New file.
Okay, so I've created
a new HTML file.
And let's just do
the boilerplate stuff.
You'd think we'd do this.
Live Canvas Editor, so...
Let me just get this boilerplate
out of the way.
So what we're gonna do
is just do a simple HTML file.
[laughter]
This is a new laptop,
and I haven't quite adjusted
to the keyboard yet.
And the Canvas tag,
I'm just gonna give it
a fixed width and height, if
you'll excuse me in this demo.
Um, so normally what we do
with the editor
is we actually have
a JavaScript listener
that listens
to the document size
and sees
when you resize the window
and resizes the Canvas
automatically,
and we'll just skip that part
in this demo.
And because I'm a little lazy,
I'm just gonna give us
an IDE,
and I'm doing awful
with typing today.
Um, so we've got
our basic HTML scene,
and let's go ahead
and save this guy.
Really quickly.
And then pop open a preview.
Okay, so there's
our blank Web page.
And let's elaborate
a little bit.
So the first thing we want to do
is create some script...
that is going to interact here
with our little Canvas guy.
So, um, let's just do
a set-up function.
Let's do a set-up function
that we're gonna call
when the page is loaded.
Anyone offended by that?
Very good.
And we're gonna get a reference
to this Canvas,
so let's see.
Canvas = document.
getElementById("canvas").
All right, so now we've got
our Canvas element.
In order to do any drawing,
you've got to get something
called the context.
And as you see here,
it's the 2-D context
because it's imagined
that, at some point,
there'll be other contexts
that let you do 3-D and...
Almaer: 4-D.
Galbraith: Other than 3-D
and 2-D, I can't really think
of what else there'd be,
but it's flexible.
So we've got our 2-D Canvas.
There is no 3-D context yet,
but there is some proposals
out there
from various browser vendors.
And once we have this stuff--
you know what,
I think I'm just gonna do some
global state here.
Almaer: So we believe
in large files and global state
in your applications.
[laughter]
Galbraith: We'll be giving
a JavaScript tips talk
after this one.
[laughter]
And let's see...
the next thing I need to do
is do a rendering loop,
and so what I'll just do
is do setInterval,
and let's just do--
let's just call it paint,
and let's kick it off every--
let's try 100 milliseconds.
That's a good start.
All right, so now we've got
a paint function
that's gonna be called
every 100 milliseconds.
And we've got a global context
that the paint function
can reference.
And let's just start rendering
the editor.
So what we're gonna do
is give ourselves some text
to render.
Oh, geez.
What just happened?
Expose for the win.
Um, hello.
World. Okay, so those will be
our lines of text in the editor.
And I'm also gonna give us...
a cursor position.
And let's put this
at this a new line.
And let's have a function here
that will render those lines
in a Canvas-based editor.
So the first thing I want to do,
every time we go
through this loop,
is clear what happens
to be there.
So this context has
this function called ClearRect.
And I'm just gonna assume
that we're always gonna be
500 by 500, sorry.
And once we do that,
then I'm gonna paint in
a background color.
Let's just go ahead
and set our background to black.
So Canvas has the notion
of a FillStyle,
which, when you do
filling operations,
is obviously what it uses
to style it.
The FillStyle--
there's also a StrokeStyle.
These are just
parsed CSS values,
so I'm just gonna set this
to whatever I had
for background there.
And let's just do
a black background,
just so we have something
to see.
And then we're gonna do
FillRect.
And then that'll give us
a basic black background.
In fact,
if I save this guy,
we should at least see that.
We'll see absolutely nothing.
Didn't we see the bug?
So set-up, set-up.
Paint.
[muttering to self]
So this is the other part
of the demo
that we were really excited
to show you.
Um, and that's how you debug
a Canvas-based application
when things just happen
to go wrong.
Um, and I see no errors
in the application.
It is not, it is not,
it is not...
[mutters to self]
Oh, yeah, yeah, why did rogue
get color there?
Anyway, that's our problem.
[muttering]
No errors. Canvas.
So can anyone see the bug?
This is...
[man speaks indistinctly]
[laughter]
Almaer: So we believe
in large files,
global variables,
and alerts.
Almaer: Console.log?
Galbraith: Oh, yeah.
That's right. Thanks.
Thank you so much
for that.
Okay, so let's give that
a try.
[hums]
You can't say it wasn't live.
Okay.
So our paint loop
is getting called--
this is fantastic news...
[people speak indistinctly]
Oh, right.
Almaer: Zero, zero.
Galbraith: Thank you so much.
Thank you. Very kind.
Muy amable.
So let's try that out.
Thank you! From the kind
gentleman in the back.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
So obviously FillRect takes
an x and a y
and width and height, obviously.
ClearRect obviously takes
an x and a y
and a width and a heighth.
Thank you. Thank you.
It's all part of the show.
So now what we're gonna do
is go through and iterate
through each line
in our little array here.
And here's where we hit
our first fun little roadblock
with Canvas.
It turns out
Canvas has one text metric API,
and that's to determine
the width of a string.
So you can't actually
figure out
what the heighth of
a string is,
and if you've worked
with these APIs,
you know that the heighth of a
string is somewhat interesting.
You can get the actual bounds
of a string
or the ascent of the font.
None of that stuff.
So we're gonna do something
kind of fun.
We're just gonna say it's 15.
[laughter]
And let's actually do a style
for the text too.
Let's just set the font
to 10-point Arial here.
And we'll deal with that
in just a...
Almaer: I think in Bespin we
take the width of the letter "M"
and we assume that
to be the height, right?
Galbraith: Yeah, yeah, yeah,
so we cheat.
Yeah, exactly.
We render
a one-character string,
and then we flip it, and then
we just assume that that's--
you know, anyways, we have ways
of tricking it
to get something
that's proportional
that does the job.
Um, and then we're
just gonna set the font--
want to--
to our font here.
And then we're just gonna have
a simple counter variable here,
and we're gonna send that
to lineheights.
And then we're gonna go through
and render each line.
Now to do that, we also need
to have a foreground.
I'll do that really quick.
White on black, everyone's
favorite color scheme.
And...
FillStyle = foreground.
Perfect.
Okay, and now we can--
FillText is the API that we need
for filling text.
And is it x,y first
and then the text,
or the text and then x,y?
We'll find out live.
On the fly.
Um, let's do lines[i],
and let's say 0, y.
That feels right.
That feels good.
And then we will +=
the lineheight.
Okay. How many people think
it's actually gonna work?
[laughter]
Huge confidence in the aud--
well, I didn't anticipate
this kind of a failure.
Really?
There we go.
Undefined!
Awesome. All right, so looks
like I got my length wrong.
Oh, and we're gonna be
continually doing this
forever and ever.
All right, so the next time,
can I stop or do I have to--
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Let's stop that script.
No, FillText is right.
It's just my loop
is going madly out of control
to the point where I think
I may have to kill the...
it's all part of the fun
of browsing in your...
man: Boo!
Galbraith: Quite often--
quite often we will see
that I will have no lost work
whatsoever.
Almaer: That's actually
an interesting point.
The very first prototype
of Bespin,
a core feature was that it's
constantly saving your state,
even though, if you haven't done
a save yet.
So if you're going through,
you're editing something,
you get a phone call,
you go home,
you open up Bespin at home.
And it will replay everything
including your undo/redo cue,
so you can hit Ctrl-Z,
Apple-Z,
and it's right back
where it starts.
Galbraith: There we are.
Yes. Well "i" is less than...
Thank you very much.
Before you make--before
you belittle me too much,
just come up on stage...
Um, so let's try this now.
Um, great, so we've got
rendered text
and the final thing
we wanted to show you
is actually handling
keyboard input.
And we'll just do--
should we just do
a document.onkeypress?
both: Sure.
Galbraith: Onkeypress =
handlekeypress.
Sure,
let's just call it that.
And give us
a handlekeypress function.
Okay, so now we have
a neat little event
that's been passed in
and so what we can do here
is say,
"if (lines.length
< (pos.row -1))..."
then we're just going to add
a new string
to the lines array.
And then we'll do
a lines[pos.row],
and we'll just have it add in
whatever we happen
to have passed in,
so charCode.
Then how do you get
an actual character
from the charCode?
fromCharCode, right?
Did I get that right?
So now with any luck--
and I've had very little in this
live coding demonstration--
we'll have an actual...
undefined.
Very nice.
So we'll probably take that
as a pass for now.
All right, so that's
how you create a basic editor
from scratch, using Canvas.
Now you notice
how it's a little choppy?
The solution there is,
of course,
to increase the resolution
of your repaint.
And we found that JavaScript
is actually really, really fast.
You can actually get really
tight with your repaint loops
and have CPU utilization
still stay pretty low.
And it becomes a lot smoother.
So that's--
that's sort of an example
of how Canvas works
and how you use Canvas
to create an editor,
and if that seemed really
tedious to you
in this short demo,
sort of imagine that
with a lot more features,
and that's kind of what it's
like to code Bespin in Canvas.
But you know, it's actually--
a lot of people,
when we first did Bespin,
sort of said, you know,
"That's crazy.
Why did you do that?
"Why didn't you just use
the built-in operating system
stuff?"
But it turns out that,
if you look at Eclipse
or IntelliJ IDEA or a lot of
the other really popular IDEs,
they've all actually written
their text-editing components
from scratch.
They actually
haven't even used
what's in the native
operating system,
or in the case of IDEA,
what's in Java.
They actually just wrote it
from scratch.
And that's what most code
editors do to give you
the kind of experience
that you want
when doing that stuff.
So as we went
through this process,
we created something called
Thunderhead as an experiment
in trying to figure out
what are the things
that you'd want as you create
components from scratch,
using Canvas,
to make life easier.
And we'll just touch on this
because it's an experiment
we're running.
We're not really sure
what we think of it right now.
But basically it's a toolkit
that lets you do something
like this--if you noticed
in our live coding example,
there's no component hierarchy
in the Canvas.
There's just this Canvas element
and a bunch of Java 2-D code.
That's not very accessible,
and it's also hard
to understand what's really
happening inside of it,
so Thunderhead is a toolkit
that lets you define a scene
inside of Canvas
using tags and content.
And also styling it
using CSS.
So we wrote a CSS parser
in JavaScript that will then let
you apply the styles
that you've done
to a Canvas scene,
so in this case, we also
actually tackled layout,
and we added layout constructs
to CSS too.
Let me just show you
how we actually use CSS
to style a part
of Bespin.
And then we'll talk
about layout in a second.
So we showed this sort
of dashboard file explorer.
And if you notice here,
we have these bars here
on the left
that have the gradient
and another image
that shows
that there's files there.
What we actually did was
implemented CSS3's image support
and WebKit's gradient support.
And we actually do this
in JavaScript
so that in JavaScript
we actually render the gradient
and then put that
into Canvas,
but we use CSS
so that you didn't have
to learn something new.
So that's what Thunderhead is.
It's this experiment to say,
okay, you can render
custom components in Canvas
that do things
that are not easy
or impossible with the DOM,
but we want to make it easy
and accessible,
so we created this toolkit
to do that.
Almaer:
[speaks indistinctly]
Galbraith: Oh, yeah,
and so...
one of the things we did
in the dashboard
as an experiment was to do
JavaScript-driven layout,
and this is
really experimental, just like,
so here's a bunch of open files,
and what can we do--
like, as you can strain
the space,
what can we do to sort of adapt
the layout
and reduce the font size
and display less
and less information
based on how much space
you want to give it?
And so JavaScript is also part
of Thunderhead.
And then the other sort
of miscellaneous thing
that we added here is doing
some intelligence stuff
when it comes to, like,
having long file names,
to be able to do truncation
in the middle
instead of at the ends.
Stuff like this.
Just miscellaneous rendering
that's not typically possible
in HTML.
And when we experimented
with layout,
we actually took a popular
third-party layout manager
in the Java world
called FormLayout--
JGoodies' Form Layout,
which already had a DSL
for doing layout,
which I showed you
but didn't really talk too much
about in this slide,
that lets you define a grid
up front
and then plug components
into it.
And we took that DSL and
just poured it over JavaScript,
just to have an experiment
to start playing around with.
How we can actually
make layout easier.
And so that's
what Thunderhead's all about.
Almaer:
So what about fast JavaScript?
We've seen all
that of these engines
are getting
not just a little bit faster,
but orders of magnitude
faster,
and so what's that
actually gonna mean
for our different
applications?
We should actually kind of
see visualizations
on what's going on here.
Uh, first of which,
do you want to talk
about garbage collection?
Galbraith:
Yeah, that's right.
So I think the key point here,
if I can go back really quick,
is that the JavaScript run-times
are getting faster.
So the first key technology
that really enabled Bespin
is Canvas.
And the second piece
that's enabling us
to do really cool things
is the fact
that each browser's getting
really fast JavaScript
run-times,
at least most browsers.
And one of the new features
that just landed
in Chrome's V8
JavaScript run-time
is generational
garbage collection.
And we wanted to spend
a second just explaining
why we think this is really
exciting to see on the Web.
Because typically with
garbage collection run-times,
which is what
all the major browsers use now,
you have objects
that are put on a heap
that represent the data
of your application,
and when you've filled up
the heap,
a garbage collection process
goes through
and cleans up all the objects
that aren't being used,
and then you can start
to put more data in there.
But a key observation
after seeing how these garbage
collectors work is that
it turns out most objects
don't live a very long time.
And so to have the garbage
collector have to walk
your entire memory space
in order to reclaim
these objects,
most of which just existed
for a transient period of time
and are now just totally bogus,
can be sped up if you have
a young generation
where you have
your objects created,
and then the collector
goes through,
and, it turns out,
destroys most of that.
And then an older generation
where the fewer long-lived
objects go to,
which represents
a much larger space--
and if you have this division,
it turns out
that you have fewer pauses
in your application.
Because as we try to do a lot
in the browser,
you'll notice that you start
to get these pauses.
That's GC.
And so Chrome getting this
just last week,
at least
in the public 2.0 release,
is really, really exciting.
And it's one of the really cool
innovations we're seeing
in these JavaScript run-times
that let us do amazing things
in the browser.
Almaer: When you're playing
around with different tools,
it'll give you
kind of visualizations
on what's actually happening
with the memory,
so as a developer you can see
what's happening
with the GC.
No need to say anything there.
Galbraith: Good.
Almaer: Let's see what happens.
To see, though, why it matters
to have these fast things,
kind of a canonical example
would be--would be,
like, to have Photoshop
in the Web,
and this is kind of one
of the stabs at doing that.
It's called Pixastic,
and it uses Canvas
to give you
a photo-editing experience.
And if we kick this off
in the different browsers,
what we're gonna go
is take the color,
and we're gonna kind
of grayscale it on the fly.
So an algorithm is running,
and you'll see Chrome kicked off
pretty quickly there.
And we're gonna start to see
the other guys come in...
[coughs]
A couple of issues
that they have--
this is why this speed-up
is really important.
It allows us to do
these applications
that we want to take
to the Web
and finally
kind of get us there,
so one of the core things
is having these runtimes
able to give us
what we need as developers
to actually write these apps
on the Web,
and we're starting to see that.
And it's kind of
a breakneck pace of innovation.
Galbraith: Did you see
those dialogues that popped up
in Firefox and Safari?
Those were the long-running
script dialogues that just say,
"Hey, wait, you know, this
script has just kept running.
Do you want to keep going?"
We're gonna talk
about what to do
with that right now
because it's exciting to see
that JavaScript's speeding up,
but it turns out
that I've jumped ahead
for a second, and before
we explain those dialogues
and how you can get rid of them,
we're gonna talk
about bottlenecks in code.
Almaer: Yeah, so there's
various bottlenecks going on
as you do your application.
There's probably one
in that Pixastic example.
We want to talk
about a bottleneck
that we ran into
with Bespin
that was actually totally fake.
JavaScript we thought
would be a huge bottleneck.
Everything we're doing
with Canvas,
all of the work
that we're doing there
is all on JavaScript Logic,
calculating what to do
to actually draw that page.
And so we have this assumption
that JavaScript was gonna be
a huge bottleneck
for the Bespin editor.
So one of the features
that we had there
was syntax highlighting,
and we used a nice
open-source package
that's really meant for,
you go to a page,
you paste in a bunch
of HTML JavaScript,
and it gives you a pretty set
of HTML that comes out.
Well, we just kind of took that
and we started to use it,
and as we're profiling
Bespin,
we were seeing that,
every time it was going through
in Ben's code,
he was painting those lines,
going through that lines array,
we were doing syntax
highlighting every time,
maybe every 25 milliseconds.
And so suddenly
in that syntax highlighter,
we saw it was doing
500 regular expressions.
So it's doing, like, 500 Regex
on every line
every time it painted.
And this was, like, a day
before we were gonna push Bespin
out there for people
to play with, and it was scary,
so we decided to rewrite
a very simple state
machine-based syntax highlighter
that would be kind of aware
of our world
where it's painting
all the time,
and we spent a bunch
of time
and got that all working
just fine.
And then we profiled it again,
and there was
no speed difference at all.
On the micro-level, we were,
like, 500 times faster,
1,000 times faster,
whatever,
but JavaScript,
it turned out,
wasn't the bottleneck
at all.
It was all the blitting code
of getting all the stuff
over to Canvas
and all these other browsery
things that were going on,
so a huge lesson was working out
what that bottleneck is
and not having assumptions
that we've had for a long time
that, oh,
it's probably JavaScript
'cause JavaScript's slow.
So we paid the price for that.
Galbraith: So this is an example
of interface latency,
and it relates
to those pop-up dialogues
that I started
to mention before.
The green indicates
that I've clicked.
And notice that I've clicked
on the word hello,
and nothing seems to be
happening.
And eventually
it will come back.
This is a problem that plagues
desktop applications
and will start to plague
Web applications.
It occurs whenever you have
computations occurring
in a client.
We want to talk to you
about why that is
and how you can solve it
really quickly.
The reason this happens
is because--and this--
all Gooey architectures
basically work in
the same way.
Let's talk in terms
of the browser.
What happens
is the operating system
will ship to you
all kinds of I/O events--
input events, sorry,
from the user.
And they land in this queue,
and then it's up to the browser
to pull these events
from this queue
and do something with them,
dispatch these events,
and as a result
of these input events,
typing on the keyboard,
moving the mouse,
we'll either execute
JavaScript code,
or the browser will actually go
to a new browser page
because you've clicked
on the Go button or something
to go to another page.
But the key point is
there's one process,
one thread
that's doing that,
and if you have
a multi-process browser
like Google Chrome
or you have
a single-process browser
like Safari or Firefox,
it doesn't matter
because we're talking
about the scope
of a single page in this case.
That page can only do
one thing at a time.
And so that's why you have
these interfaces
that freeze up.
So the solution is to actually
create background thread
that does anything,
any computation,
that's likely to lock up
that browser.
But, unfortunately,
on the Web,
we don't have
background threads.
But when you think about it,
XHR...
is--this thing that's let us
go and make requests
to other servers
is essentially
a single-purpose
background thread
that lets us go and do that,
and the browser manages that,
and we've been able
to use things like Gears
and other plug-ins like Java
and Flash to sort of give us
something to do
in the background.
And HTML5 gives us something
called Web Workers,
which also gives us
this background thread concept.
But it gives us this concept
with a big difference.
Threads are considered
deprecated by some
of the big thinkers
in computer science
because there's something
called shared state.
Because threads have access
to all of your variables,
just as your main thread has,
and so what happens typically
with most developers
is we create threads,
we do things in the background,
we feel really great
about our abilities,
but inevitably these threads
start to touch the state
that the other threads see,
and they do that
in ways
that we just can't predict.
And even though on paper,
you'd look at the problem space
and you think, "Hey, I got that.
I can do that.
"I can create a program
that's gonna behave
in ways I predict,
using threads,"
but, in practice, we've seen
that threads inject
all kinds of unpredictable bugs
into applications,
so workers take concurrency
and do it a little differently,
where they give you basically
what you'd recognize
as a thread,
but a thread that has
no access to your state--
to the main thread state.
All you can do
is just pass messages to it
and receive responses
in return.
That's the big innovation
that has a lot of people
feeling like workers may be
the right way to do concurrency.
And so we have a couple of demos
to show you
why this comes in so handy.
The first demo we wanted
to show you is, frankly,
a demo that shows you
how sensitive we are
to interface latency.
It turns out
that you can sense delays
of a really short period
of time.
I've got code here
that just goes off and sleeps
essentially for the number
of time that you see here.
And so if I click
on this button,
you'll see that I register
pretty much
an instantaneous response.
It seems like, to me,
that the program responds
right when I click
on the button.
But as I start to add
the delay,
it starts to feel--what would
you call--a little sluggish.
100 milliseconds isn't bad.
You can still tell
the difference
between 50 milliseconds
and 100 milliseconds,
but as we step up,
you start to see
that even a 1/10 of a second
difference makes me feel
like the program
isn't quite responding,
isn't quite keeping up
with me.
And it gets really bad
at 350 milliseconds.
And what's the emotional
response that you have
when a program doesn't respond
right away,
when it's sluggish?
How do you feel
about that program?
If you're like most people,
you hate it.
You really hate using it.
You really hate
using these programs,
and we're talking about
really small details, right?
We're just talking
about a 1/10 of a second,
a 1/15 of a second--
not a 1/15 of a second,
like an 1/8 of a second,
but it really, really matters.
And so this is the challenge
as we start to create
richer JavaScript
applications,
sure, we can do a lot more
on the client,
but if you tie up
that main browser thread
for these small periods
of time,
in this case
even just 50 milliseconds,
the difference
between 50 milliseconds
and 100 milliseconds,
you've started to create
an interface
that isn't really responsive.
And once you do that,
people just start to feel
like, "Hey, this is sluggish.
This is not really an
application I enjoy using."
And so it's really important
that none of
your JavaScript code takes--
has the ability to execute
for longer--
I mean, pick your threshold.
I would say even,
like, 50 milliseconds.
If it's gonna take longer
than 50 milliseconds,
you've got to put it
somewhere else
other than
the main browser thread.
So where do you put it?
Well, you put it
in the background.
Um, why don't we actually
just--
should we just switch
to that demo?
Almaer: Yes, the main one?
Galbraith: Yeah...
Almaer: How about we switch
to this one?
Galbraith: Yeah, perfect.
Yup.
Almaer: So this is a demo
done by the same guy
that did that cool, fancy
iPhone,
on-the-fly Canvas thing.
And what he's doing here--
the Firefox is gonna rotate,
and that's his visual way
of showing
that the application
is responsive.
But what's really happening is,
he's got JavaScript code
that's gonna simulate
this annealing,
which is gonna calculate
the shortest path
between all of these points.
And we're gonna kick it off here
without workers,
and you see immediately
the browser froze,
which we can tell
from the Firefox icon.
And it's gonna go through
and do this,
you know, CPU-intensive thing
in these tests,
and suddenly it's gonna come
back and do the calculation,
and the browser's back.
That entire time,
the browser's frozen.
We do it with workers.
Firefox is happy.
We can interact
with the UI.
And, boom, then it comes in.
So it makes a huge difference
because he took that calculation
and he ran it off
in this Web worker space.
And so we got fast JavaScript
now, and we've got workers,
which allow us to run
that fast JavaScript
off of the main thread
and give us what
we really want,
which is the UI
responsiveness.
Galbraith:
One more quick demo.
Um, some of you
may be thinking,
"Okay, you know,
I really don't care
"about 50 milliseconds,
100 milliseconds.
I really--I really just don't
think it matters that much."
One of the other reasons
why it's important
to make use of workers
is what happens, frankly,
when you tie up
the UI thread
for a certain period
of time.
So this is an example,
and it's a very simple example.
Let's view the source.
When the page loads, I go
into this runTest function,
and this runTest function--
can I bump up the font size?--
this runTest function,
the first thing it does
is it sets an interval--
timeout--a timer
that, every second, just logs
something to the console.
And then I go inside of
a loop
inside of this runTest
function,
and this loop is gonna take
a fairly long time.
This tests something
really important.
And it's another aspect
of workers
I don't think
we mentioned yet.
And that is
that workers will not--
the workers will not interrupt
JavaScript code
to update the UI ever.
Because what happens is
you start a worker,
and when the worker finishes,
it has a callback
that is inside
of your main JavaScript code
that then has access
to your main application state.
And that callback will
never preempt--interrupt
an executing function
that you have in JavaScript,
you would think.
But it turns out,
when you have really
long-running JavaScript code
like I'm about to show you--
Where's my little console guy?
Go.
I saw this guy go here.
All right,
so I've locked up the browser,
so I've got this tight loop.
And, eventually, Safari shows me
this slow script dialogue
that says, "Hey, listen,
do you want interrupt this?"
This is an exceedingly poor
user experience
to have this thing pop up,
as you would imagine.
But then the other
interesting thing is--
I haven't given this demo
on a constrained display.
Where's my fancy expose?
Is that gonna work?
Let's just have it continue,
and then I'm gonna have to go
back over to this debugger
and show you this piece.
The sort of scary thing is...
that it interrupted--
it broke this contract of
interruptions.
So if you go back
and look at the source code,
my code says that I have a loop
that interrupts for,
what is that,
100,000 or a million?
100,000 iterations.
And then after the 100,000
iterations, my loop stops,
and then, in theory,
this timeout should occur.
But if you look
at the debugger,
when Safari presented
that dialogue to the user,
it stopped the execution
of my top-level function
and started allowing the timer
to occur.
And then when I hit "Continue,"
it stopped the timer
and went back
to my top-level function,
finished that,
and then went back to the timer.
In other words, it breaks
a fundamental assumption
that you make about the safety
of your application.
So in other words, it's not only
a poor user experience
to do things
on the main UI thread,
you can actually,
in some browsers,
break your application.
So you really just want
to make sure
that you use workers, I guess,
is the sales pitch there.
[man asks inaudible question]
Uh, I doubt it.
Um, I doubt it.
I haven't tried Chrome.
Um...
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Almaer:
So how do we use workers?
Well, as you're
in a code editor,
you're doing things
like syntax highlighting.
We also are doing detailed
retail--real time analysis.
So we've got JSLint,
for example,
in your JavaScript file
that's running constantly
and telling you
if there are any syntax errors
in real time.
But if that calculation
was running in this way
on the main thread,
then you'd be typing,
and there'd be all
of those same pauses.
So we take all
of these different modules
that are doing
interesting analysis,
and we run those
in the workers.
So that's always happening
in this kind of side world,
and then, when it's got
an answer, it can tell us
what's going on in this
real time syntax analysis
in that example.
Now to get this working,
the browsers have
still slightly different APIs
for the Web worker API.
So we have a worker facade,
which we're going to split off
into its own very small,
little open-source project,
but you can look at it in the
Bespin source code right now.
Bespin is, of course,
100% open-source.
And what it does is
it sits on top of both
the Web worker API
and on top of Gears,
so if you're in a browser
that doesn't support
Web workers yet,
but you do have Gears,
then it'll work.
And finally it will do
a set interval
to try and just make it,
you know,
actually execute the code
automatically for you.
And it adds in functionality
that browsers don't have,
so Safari, for example,
doesn't have
an import scripts method
that you really need
within workers
because workers are running
in their separate
little process.
They don't have access
to the browser's document object
or any of those things.
By design. This is great for
security and everything else.
So part of the API
is you can then import
these other scripts.
And we do that ourselves
in Bespin
where we say,
"Here's a worker.
"And here's
this nice Bespin Core space
that you can then go ahead
and do particular things."
One of the things
that we do here is,
if you look
at the Bespin code,
it's an event-based system
with just publish/subscribe,
and that is built in
to the workers.
A big pain that we had was
marshaling over these objects
to the workers,
having 'em do things,
and getting it back
into our world.
So what we did is,
we have a worker
with its own
little Bespin script
that allows you
to create a worker and say,
"I want to subscribe
to the document change event.
"And I'm gonna do something,
and when I'm done,
I'm gonna publish
this other event."
And we marshal it
over this barrier
automatically.
And so now we have
this facade.
It's very trivial for us
to take a piece of code,
see that it's taken
more than 50 milliseconds,
and make it run
in a worker instead.
And it just kind of goes
through the different issues
that we've had.
For example, one thing
that we found right away was,
we started to do all
this real time syntax analysis,
and the CPU has gone
through the roof
because we were firing off
all of these workers.
You couldn't do that before.
We were stuck
in this single thread.
Now we can do all this stuff,
but we're kind of taking over
the user's machine.
So we've got a little
kind of slicing algorithm
that's in there now
because we, unfortunately,
don't have yield and concepts
like that
in our world that you have
to start thinking about,
so you're kind of doing
a little bit of work
and kind of checking in
to make sure
that you're not doing too much
and firing off
too many workers at once
and things like that.
So if you want
to do worker stuff,
we've gone through some
of that pain,
and you can just take a look
at our worker facade
to see what it's like
to actually use these things.
Galbraith: So we've been talking
about Canvas, fast JavaScript,
and Web workers as technologies
that really enable us
to do some amazing things
in the browser.
The last thing
that has us really excited
is removing the cliffs
that we've experienced
as developers.
Um, for us, the cliffs
that we have--
there's this notion
that you can develop
in one environment,
but only get so far
and have to jump
to another environment
and sort of hit this wall
where you have to start over
and learn
a whole new set of tools
just because you want to do
something subtly different.
For example, on the iPhone,
you can get
to a certain distance
creating a Web application
in mobile Safari,
but if you want to integrate
into some of the, you know,
device-specific APIs, you've got
to stop using HTML, CSS,
and all these other Web
technologies that you know
and learn Objective-C
and a whole new toolchain
and so forth.
And we see that these cliffs
over and over and over again
that destroy productivity
in the industry,
and so we're really excited
to see
how the emergence
of technologies
that just say, "Hey,
just take the Web stack--
"the Web platform and use that
wherever you happen to be,
on the desktop, on mobile,
or whatever."
Fluid and Mozilla Prism
and Appcelerator Titanium
are three open-source
environments that do this.
Adobe AIR is
a great commercial environment
that also is experimenting here,
that's saying,
"Hey, listen, how can we take
a Web application
and run this
in a desktop sandbox?"
And Gears has explored this.
And then there's this
application called PhoneGap
that actually takes
the native iPhone APIs
and exposes them
through JavaScript objects
to Web code that lets you take
Web applications
and actually access APIs
that are really, formally,
only available
to native applications.
And so this is
an emerging trend
that we're really, really
excited about.
And we have a desktop version
of Bespin
in development using some
of these technologies
that we'll talk about later on
in the year.
Um, but we're also
really excited about, um,
the Palm Pre.
Almaer: Yeah, so they've
taken this to the next level.
We saw Michael talk about that
yesterday in the keynote.
And just like--well, everyone's
programming in this Web world.
How are we gonna compete
with Apple and the like?
Let's make the platform
just the Web platform.
And so everything that you're
used to in the HTML5 land,
and they've got some extra APIs
that they talked about,
now as Web developers,
we can really just start using
the same skills
and the same APIs
to build these apps.
So this is very exciting
for us at Mozilla
to see the Web kind of get
past these cliffs
and let you write
some more APIs.
Galbraith: So the other place
we're seeing this too is,
with Jetpack and Chrome
extensions, this idea of using
the Web as the extension
platform instead of [indistinct]
or, you know, other proprietary
sandboxes, APIs.
The Web is winning.
Almaer: So talk about Jetpack
very quickly.
In the background here,
you'll see Bespin going off
and creating a Jetpack.
And you can see
this video online,
but what Jetpack is is a way
to extend the browser
with very,
very simple Web APIs,
and the Chrome guys have been
talking about their extensions,
which is very, very similar.
You don't have to learn
the proprietary world.
It's just HTML, CSS,
and JavaScript.
And it was really, really cool
for us to be able
to take Bespin,
and, in the fly--
in the browser in Firefox,
add a little piece
of functionality to the Chrome
of the browser, like add
in a little status bar
that tells you
your Gmail notifications
and, in real time, just say,
"Install it right now."
A little pop-up says,
"You want to install this guy?"
You say, "Yes," and you've
just extended your browser.
You don't have to restart it.
You don't have to do anything.
So especially
for development now,
it's getting very,
very easy,
and hopefully a lot easier
as these guys kind of progress,
both the Jetpack
and the Chrome Extensions,
where the browser itself will
just be this Web environment
for you to extend.
And it really lowers
the barrier.
We've already got
8,000 extensions
or add-ons on Firefox,
and that's with things being
a lot harder to use
than what Web people
are used to.
So we're really jazzed
about extending the browser
in new directions too.
Galbraith: So we've kind of
talked about the Web platform
and the features
of the Web platform
that we've used in Bespin.
We just wanted to spend
a couple of minutes
at the end of the talk
talking about where we're going,
and then we'll have
a few minutes left over
for Q&A.
As we develop Bespin,
we're really interested
in how we can do something
that doesn't look like this.
We really want to keep
Bespin accessible
and friendly and capture
a lot of people's attention
who traditionally
have eschewed IDEs.
But at the same time,
it's kind of a challenge
because it's one thing
to look at this and say,
"Yeah, we don't want
this big, bloated interface."
It's another to say,
"Well, wait,
"actually all of these
are somewhat useful,
so how do you start
picking them out?"
So we're experimenting
with interface techniques
that will enable us to let
you spend most of your time
looking at all of your code
and letting you access
other features
without having to have docking
panels and things like that.
We don't know if they're
a good idea or not, frankly,
but we're playing around
in that direction.
Almaer: And then fits in
with the Wave thing
that's going on
and the playback APIs
and things like that.
We want to integrate
with that world
where we, from the beginning,
made Bespin
this very social tool.
So you can collaborate
and things like that,
but we want to go
further than that.
So what's going on here
is you have
a social bar kind of
on the right side
that has your different
coders
in your project network,
whatever,
and there's
this little chat thing.
And it's not just like, okay,
here's a IM chat that's over
on the side,
it integrates
with your coding experience.
So it's associated
with the file
that you're working on.
You can also maybe select
a piece of the code
and see what was said
about that particular code,
who wrote that,
what were people discussing.
So we want to tie these things
into the code
in a better way
than just having comments
that people don't like
to update.
So we've got that,
and then we have
the next piece,
which is the timeline view,
where you can just real time see
all of the commits
that have happened,
different tags
for that particular version,
and you can, on the fly,
go back and just see
what's happened.
So the file will change
as you go back in time.
So you can really kind of see
what's going on
in that particular piece
of code
and obviously make it
very social
with your various friends.
This is Brendan Eich,
the inventor of JavaScript.
We have a feature going
in Bespin
where you can follow people.
So I could follow Brendan
while he hacks on code.
Luckily, he hacks
on all open-source stuff,
so there's no issues
with doing stuff
within a company
or what-have-you.
But wouldn't it be cool
to see what it's like
being Brendan and see what
it's like with him writing code.
And we want to kind of open up
this model
so we can start following people
and then even play back
what they were doing.
So you're in with a teammate--
a team member,
you had to go to the doctor's,
you come back,
it'd be pretty cool to see
what was the actual code
that they went ahead
and did and go through,
change the playback metaphor,
and then real time
just kind of see
exactly what they were typing
at that time.
So these are some of the things
that tie in with Wave
and social and real time
that we're playing around with.
Galbraith: We think that having
an environment like this
sort of can unlock open-source
in a way
that we haven't seen before.
We think open-source
is really just--
what we've seen
is the tip of the iceberg.
And that if we had
an environment
where people could go in,
and, instead of having
to download a dev tool
and figure out
where code is and figure out
how to submit code
back to the project,
they just hit a Web page,
boom, you're in the code,
you can immediately start
editing code,
click a button,
submit a patch to a patch queue,
and have people review it.
Or you can actually follow
the project leaders around
and watch what they code.
Or you can actually say,
"Okay, show me
what they coded yesterday."
When you come back to your desk
and you've seen
that the code base is changed
because a bunch of patches
have been committed and you
can actually play those back
and see them instead of parsing
DIV files,
we think that will revolutionize
open-source
and help take it
to the next level.
And so that's where we're headed
with Bespin.
Um, and, in general,
we're really excited to see
the Web kind of go
from the AJAX space,
which was, "Can we actually do
cool applications
with a Web platform?"
to what we're seeing emerge,
which is,
we can create
the world's best applications
on this platform,
not just--not just flight,
but flight with style,
I guess you'd say.
Anyway, thanks very much
for coming to the talk.
We really appreciate it.
Almaer: Thank you.
[applause]
Galbraith: So we have, like,
a minute and a half
for questions, I guess.
Should we just, like,
take a question?
Yeah, okay,
so if you go to the microphone
to ask a question,
there's one right behind you.
Um...
Yeah.
man: So how did you guys
implement mouse detection
and mouse events for--
Galbraith: Using the DOM.
So we have a top-level DOM
listener that's registered
on the entire
visible Canvas area.
And when you click on that area,
then we translate
in our JavaScript code
what that means for us.
So we figure out
what line you were over...
man: So then you're using
the worker essentially
to do the calculation,
or are you doing it
on the main thread itself?
Galbraith: So, stuff like that,
we do on the main thread.
So, workers--you don't want
to have your entire application
in workers because the challenge
of marshaling
and demarshaling state
would be enormous.
You want to isolate
that functionality
that has the potential to be
an interface bottleneck.
50 milliseconds, it turns out,
is a really long time
in terms of computation.
And so, yeah, stuff like taking
a raw x,y
and figuring out what line
that corresponds to,
things like that, that's
all done on the main thread.
man: Okay, and only HTML, CSS,
and JavaScript right now?
Or any other languages
that you're supporting
for syntax highlighting?
Galbraith: Oh, as far
as syntax highlighting,
we actually have more
than that right now.
Almaer: Yes, some people
have contributed, you know,
Python, PHP, Ruby,
a whole slew.
It's very easy to add them.
The goal is we want
to have
a syntax highlighter
plug-in system that understands
eMac style, vi style,
TextMate bundles,
so we don't have to reinvent
yet another wheel.
man: Cool.
See you at Bespin. Thanks.
Galbraith: Thank you.
man: Hi, there.
[clears throat]
I'm very interested
in the collaborative aspects
of the tool,
and I was just wondering,
what are your capabilities
in terms of, you know,
sharing code
and searching for code
that other people have done
and so on, you know, like
functions and all that stuff?
Galbraith; So right now,
our model for collaboration
is really focused on helping you
have a social network
of people that you're interested
in coding with.
In a company,
that would be your team.
In the open-source world,
that would be the contributors
to a project,
and it can also be people
that you just like to follow.
And the ability
to watch them code,
the ability to code together
on a file,
the ability to do traditional
VCS things like,
"Show me who's done what
in a file,"
that's really
all we focused on.
If I've understood
your question,
then, like, finding code
that people have written
that does X
or stuff like that,
we haven't thought too much
about that.
We'd love to have you come
join us on the project
and help us think
through those issues.
Almaer: Yeah, so we're excited
the fact
that all of this code
is in the Cloud.
And so we can have intelligent
agents watching the code.
So, for example, we want--
you're in a project,
and you say you want
to target IE6,
and I'm using the prototype
library and things like that,
and, on the fly,
as you write some code,
it can say, "Hey, there's a
known bug where,
"if you do this, this,
and this,
and you're targeting these
browsers, this is what happens."
So we want to add stuff
on the server
that's just kind of
constantly watching the code
and would allow you to search
across projects
and do stuff like that.
Galbraith:
We're out of time,
so we'd love to talk
to you after.
Thank you.